>>> A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS
DECIDED NOT TO CHARGE TWO
ATLANTA POLICE OFFICERS IN THE
DEATH OF A BLACK MAN THEY
DETAINED IN 2020.
>> THE OFFICER SHOT AND KILLED
27-YEAR-OLD RAYSHARD BROOKS
OUTSIDE A WENDY'S RESTAURANT.
BROOKS WAS RUNNING FROM THE
OFFICERS AFTER HE FAILED A
SOBRIETY TEST.
HE FOUGHT WITH THE OFFICERS AND
TOOK A TASER FROM ONE OF THEM.
NICK VALENCIA IS LIVE WITH MORE
ON THE DECISION.
NICK.
>> Reporter: HEY THERE, VICTOR
AND ALISYN, THE PRESS CONFERENCE
JUST WRAPPED UP FROM SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR PETE SCANDALACOUS, HE
SAID THEY'RE MOVING TO DISMISS
THE CHARGES AGAINST THE TWO
OFFICERS INVOLVED IN THE
SHOOTING DEATH OF 27-YEAR-OLD
RAYSHARD BROOKS.
JUST TO REMIND EVERYONE HOW WE
GOT HERE.
PAUL HOWARD WAS THE PROSECUTOR
IN FULTON COUNTY WHO DECIDED TO
CHARGE THESE TWO OFFICERS AFTER
THEY USED DEADLY AGAINST BROOKS.
HE LOST THE BID FOR D.A., AFTER
CAMPAIGNING ON THE CHARGES
BROUGHT.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WAS
RECUSED FROM THE CASE TO MAKE
WAY FOR SCADALACOUS.
UNDER GEORGIA LAW A TASER CAN BE
SEEN AS A DEADLY WEAPON.
IT WAS DURING THE STRUGGLE THAT
BROOKS WAS ABLE TO WRESTLE AWAY
A TASER FROM ONE OF THE OFFICERS
AND DEPLOY IT AT LEAST TWICE.
LISTEN TO HIM WHEN HE SAID
AFTERWARDS THAT RACE, HE DID NOT
BELIEVE RACE PLAYED A ROLE IN
THIS INCIDENT.
HE WAS ASKED WHAT HE WOULD SAY
TO THOSE WHO BELIEVE RACE WAS A
FACTOR.
>> BLACK LIVES DO MATTER.
I'VE SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER
REPRESENTING BLACK VICTIMS OF
CRIME.
AND I WILL TELL THEM.
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ENCOUNTERS BETWEEN POLICE AND
THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AT TIMES ARE VERY VOLATILE.
BUT I WILL ASK THEM TO LOOK AT
THE FACTS OF THIS CASE, AND THIS
ISN'T ONE OF THOSE CASES.
I DO UNDERSTAND THERE HAS TO BE
AN OUTREACH BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY, AND
I ENCOURAGE THAT OUTREACH TO
CONTINUE.
>> GOING TO THE ATLANTA MAYOR'S
STATEMENT NEXT.
SHORTLY AFTER THE ANNOUNCEMENT
WAS MADE TO DISMISS THOSE
CHARGES THE ATLANTA MAYOR ISSUED
A STATEMENT HERE.
I'LL READ PART OF THAT.
MY HEART CONTINUES TO ACHE FOR
THE FAMILY OF RAYSHARD BROOKS.
HE WAS A FATHER WHOSE ABSENCE
WILL FOREVER BE FELT BY OUR
COMMUNITY.
THIS MATTER WAS REFERRED TO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
I RESPECT THE ROLE THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR PLAYED IN THIS CASE.
AS MAYOR, I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
BUILDING THE BONDS OF TRUST
BETWEEN OUR RESIDENTS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL WHO SERVE US.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR DID SAY
THAT HE WAS IN TOUCH WITH
MULTIPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE ATLANTA
POLICE DEPARTMENT AHEAD OF HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT ANTICIPATING THAT
THERE COULD BE SOME REACTION ON
THE STREETS.
WE SAW SOME DEMONSTRATIONS IN
JUNE 2020 AFTER RAYSHARD BROOKS
WAS KILLED.
SOME OF THOSE DEMONSTRATIONS
TURNED VIOLENT WHICH WAS ALSO
TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY AT THIS
PRESS CONFERENCE.
HERE'S WHAT THE ATLANTA POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAD TO SAY ABOUT
POTENTIAL DEMONSTRATIONS.
>> WE HAVE FAITH IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SUSPECT AND WE RESPECT
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR'S
DECISION IN THIS CASE.
OFFI